tout
et
bonne nouvelle pour 83 20 enfants
roumains adoptée ils vont enfin arriver
en france l'adoption un drôle de trafic
sous shao ses fruits l'histoire va vite
en tchécoslovaquie vaclav havel éternel
dissident élu ce matin président de la
république
deux policiers tués à nîmes hier soir
ils ont été abattus par un gangster en
cavale tout est lui aussi dans la
fusillade
philippe poupon hors de danger et son
bateau avait chaviré avec loïck peyron
ils ont réussi à le redresser
bonsoir on l'a appris en fin de matinée
les parents français qui attendaient
d'adopter depuis trois ans des enfants
roumains vont enfin avoir satisfaction
les nouvelles autorités de bucarest ont
décidé de laisser partir ses enfants
vers la france
ces enfants sont 83 mais dans le même
temps de paix hier on découvre de chez
des choses bien étranges dans la
politique de ceausescu en matière
d'adoption et de natalité
c'était même un véritable trafic vers
l'étranger tout cela lié à une politique
nataliste forcelais and gas burget ce
jour là roxana sept ans retrouvé ses
parents adoptants dans une chambre
d'hôtel de bucarest
c'était il y a deux mois un week end
entre parenthèses presque clandestins
aujourd'hui roxana a quitté son
orphelinat
d'ici quelques heures elle sera en
france comme elle
quatre-vingt deux autres enfants
roumains vont maintenant rejoindre des
familles qui les attendent depuis
plusieurs années elodie d'orinel et les
autres dont on a dit beaucoup de choses
qu'ils avaient été arrachés à leurs
familles
vendu par chaouchi ce coût à l'étranger
jean pierre bastid avez vous acheté
d'amiens absolument pas j'ai purement et
simplement vers 600 dollars à la banque
de commerce hellfire
même ses 600 $ servaient à payer les
frais d'avocat les frais de notaire et à
subvenir aux besoins de l'enfant
avez vous un jour imaginé ou su que ses
enfants pouvaient avoir été arrachés à
leur famille pour être vendues à
l'étranger
non la seule chose que je savais
concernant damien ce que la maman de
damien d abandonner parce qu'elle
n'avait pas de quoi le nourrir pour tous
la même procédure
accor de la dass en france dépôt de 4 à
5000 francs à la banque du commerce
extérieur roumaine enfin acte notarié
d'adoption le visa de sortie de l'enfant
ne dépende est ensuite que de la
signature de chaouchi sco lui même
effectivement les taounat a essayé
pendant des années des années ça a
commencé
20 1984 de bloquer non pas les adoptions
mais les départs des enfants vers
l'étranger pour pouvoir par ce billet
est par le biais des parents qui étaient
amenés à un état psychologique
épouvantable obtenir une pression sur
les médias en france
et même si les hommes politiques qui
avaient commencé justement à ce moment à
critiquer de plus en plus cela l'action
du gouvernement roumain
en somme des enfants otages en somme des
enfants otages et finalement aussi des
parents adoptants français otages aussi
de cette situation où tu cherchais
seront pratiqués à une sorte de
terrorisme humanitaire
damien adoptées il ya trois ans attend
aujourd'hui son demi frère on lui a
promis que d'orinel serait là dans cette
chambre qui l'attend pour le réveillon
du 1er janvier le gouvernement
provisoire de roumanie peu à peu
reprendre le pays en main nous allons y
revenir le calme s'installe un petit peu
partout notamment à bucarest où la neige
est arrivée brusquement signe réel
d'amélioration les militaires rentrent
dans leur caserne à bruno l'adresse
les roumains possède de nouveaux
dirigeants un nouveau drapeau
une nouvelle république ils ont retrouvé
cet après midi leur ancienne rue symbole
de la normalisation ses chars qui ont
aidé à renverser le dictateur retrouvent
le chemin de leurs casernes
le pouvoir est désormais aux mains du
peuple du moins à ceux qui se proclament
aujourd'hui son représentant bucarest
comme l'ensemble du pays à retrouver la
paix c'est par milliers que les agents
de la securitate et ont été arrêtés
pourtant quelques centaines de ce que
l'on appelle plus ici que les
terroristes se cachent encore malgré les
intenses recherches dont ils font
l'objet dans cet appartement du centre
de la capitale
on retrouve la cagoule derrière laquelle
se cachent ceux qui résistent encore
quelques centaines d'hommes qui font
toujours peur
exemple dans le métro on contrôle
soigneusement les papiers on ouvre les
sacs on fouille les voyageurs mais c'est
finalement sur les marchés que l'espoir
revient après des années de famine
organisée de patates de haricots de
mauvais saucisses on re découvre les
oranges et les quartiers de viande
spectacle extraordinaire aux yeux du
peuple de ses toutes nouvelles
démocraties première décision pour le
gouvernement provisoire mis en place par
le front de salut national
le gouvernement s'est prononcé pour le
multipartisme pour la presse libre aussi
mais il a accepté aussi de continuer à
appartenir au pacte de varsovie toute
une série de décisions rapides donc
stéphane magnier vous êtes avec nous en
direct à buc à bucarest oui
effectivement il semble que le front de
salut national stéphane et ce nouveau
gouvernement ont vraiment repris le pays
en un ce soir
oui vous avez tout à fait raison hervé
on est d'ailleurs entré dans une espèce
de période de transition qui est marqué
par fait n'est ce que vous voyez qui
tombe finement depuis ce matin sur
bucarest mais qui va s'envoler
je savais qu'en tout simplement en avril
lorsqu auront lieu les prochaines
élections alors justement qu'est ce que
c'est que cette période de transition
est passé c'est très simple c'est un
moment où se combinent et du front de
salut national détient tous les pouvoirs
absolument tous les pouvoirs non
seulement il peut il détient là
le pouvoir sur l'armée contrôle
l'énergie contrôle absolument tout ce
qui est normal dans un gouvernement mais
il peut même faire et défaire à tout
instant ce même gouvernement
alors qu'est ce qu'il va faire dans les
jours qui viennent et bien c'est toute
la question est ce que il va se préparer
avec des élections et se présenter en
bloc aux élections avec des tendances à
l'intérieur ou est-ce qu'au contraire il
va laisser des partis politiques se
créent en dehors de lui
eh bien c'est ce que l'on va savoir
c'est ce qui va se passer dans les
semaines qui viennent et qui va être
déterminant pour l'avenir et la solidité
de la démocratie en roumanie alors
pourquoi
et bien tout simplement parce que le
pouvoir de ce comité du front de salut
national
il est détenu sa légitimité il vient
tout simplement de la télévision ce sont
des gens qui se sont retrouvés là qu'ils
se sont adressé à la nation qui ont fait
penser que ça y est c'était gagné que
timochenko avait perdu le pouvoir alors
qu'il pouvait encore le détenir
et cette télévision a joué un rôle
considérable on a beaucoup dit ces
derniers jours
mais aujourd'hui cette télévision est
très consciente du rôle qu'elle a joué
dans les périodes passées ne sait pas
encore très bien comme le commencer du
front de salut national quel rôle elle
va jouer dans les jours qui viennent
elle est elle aussi dans cette période
de transition martine laroche-joubert et
gilles berrut gens sont allés la voir
toujours sous haute surveillance
la division de bucarest bâtiment
transformé en forteresse
l'année dernière nous avons entendu
kokora pâle un attentat restait possible
aussi l'armée sur le qui-vive protège
les journalistes roma théophile c'est
praga spécialiste en économie travaille
ici depuis 20 ans
voix c'est la championne de la rédaction
plus que l on a tiré sur le peuple
on a presque fait souvent un symbôle le
dernier dix années c'était une peur on
peut dire pour les journalistes parce
que il faut avoir des des phrases
typiques de dire pas de mensonge mais
dit il vient c'est une talent de t d
qu'il y ait aujourd'hui tout dire et le
mode horde pas toujours facile pour le
nouveau pouvoir faire encore mais
l'enthousiasmé l'emportent pas de chasse
aux sorcières parmi les journalistes
pour le moment seul le directeur a
changé l'important pour tous et d'abord
de ne pas décevoir souple ont pris des
risques
la nuit de la révolution avant le
bouclage ont été apportées et par des
amateurs
et si beaucoup beaucoup d 4d rachis
profil mais parler
jean va être père a eu beaucoup de
courage et les amateurs ont pu beaucoup
de courage pour
participer avec tous les gens aux
événements
important qu'il y ait malgré les dégâts
le délabrement la télévision roumaine va
tourner plus que jamais l'armée restera
donc ici mon temps pour maintenir la
gare première révolution vidéo en direct
la télévision appartient maintenant aux
roumains elle sera ce que vous comptez
en france voilà et c'est ce que l'on
pouvait dire ce soir ici à bucarest de
la situation je vous propose de vous
retrouver en direct donc comme on le
fait déjà depuis beaucoup de jours
depuis le début de cette révolution
particulière en roumanie dans nos
prochaines éditions
merci stéphane merci à tous nos envoyés
spéciaux avec quelques jours de recul on
commence maintenant à mieux comprendre
ce qui s'est passé en roumanie commencé
déclenché cette insurrection et on a
parlé au début dès le début d'un rôle
actif joué par les soviétiques alors
jacques merlino on commence c'est vrai
maintenant avoir plus d'informations sur
ce sujet we have et il semble en effet
que l'on possède de plus en plus d'
indice montrant que moscou fut très
actif dans les événements roumain ce
soir nous pouvons donner au moins cinq
informations d'abord un petit rappel qui
ne manque pas de sel c'était le 15
novembre dernier laurent fabius
président l'assemblée nationale
rencontre à moscou mikhaïl gorbatchev à
la fin de l'entretien laurent fabius
parle des pays de l'est aux journalistes
qui l'entourent et leur dit monsieur
double check a devant lui un grand
avenir politique
puis dans la conversation général qui
suit avec les conseillers de gorbatchev
l'un de ses conseillers pas là de
ceausescu précise même si ceausescu et
réélu triomphalement au prochain congrès
cela ne veut pas dire qu'il terminera
l'année
le message de ses confidences en demi
teinte est clair les soviétiques
voulaient faire savoir qu'ils
contrôlaient la situation
en roumanie et en tchécoslovaquie
seconde information lors du quatorzième
congrès du parti communiste roumain
nicolae ceaucescu a laissé entendre
qu'ils se préparaient à remettre en
cause les frontières entre la roumanie
et l'urss
une phrase qui a suscité de vives
inquiétudes à moscou troisième
information nous l'avons déjà dit
plusieurs facettes semaine yann eliès
coup l'homme fort du nouveau boulevard
romain est un proche de barbacha
quatrième informations le nouveau
premier ministre est très romane l'écart
est hier soir sur cette antenne
qu'il avait été propulsé premier
ministre de manière très spontanée
en fait cet homme n'est pas n'importe
qui son père fut membre du comité
central du parti communiste roumain et
est actuellement en général en retraite
on dit que pétri romane aurait été
préparée soigneusement à ses nouvelles
fonctions
enfin un personnage intéressant est
apparu dans le nouveau gouvernement
roumain il s'agit d'un nicolas militants
il est actuellement ministre la défense
très discret on la page de la télévision
et on ne possède de lui que cette photo
pourtant cet homme fut nommé par
ceausescu au comité central du parti
communiste roumain en 1969 et il aurait
été écarté du pouvoir par ceausescu
car identifié comme un agent du service
de renseignement soviétique
voilà c'est 5 informations elles ne
permettent pas une conclusion définitive
mais elles sont cohérentes
elles sont encore plus lorsque l'on
rappelle que la roumanie exporte 70% de
sa production agricole vers l'urss
merci jacques et à propos des
répercussions de la révolution roumaine
en france une nouvelle contre attaque du
parti communiste français
hier hier soir dans notre journal ici
même georges marchais disait qu'il ne
savait pas tout sur la roumanie
certainement moins en tout cas que
l'ambassadeur de france à bucarest
et bien ce soir un député communiste
jean claude lefort demande au ministre
des affaires étrangères de rendre public
les dossiers de l'ambassade de france à
bucarest
dès ce soir en tchécoslovaquie vaclav
havel s'est mise au travail il a annoncé
ses premières décisions de président de
la république tchécoslovaque ce matin
l'éternel dissidents l'écrivain
mondialement connu le défenseur des
droits de l'homme a été élu c'est vrai
qu'il était le seul candidat à ce poste
mais tout de même il a été élu à
l'unanimité par une assemblée à majorité
de député communiste à prague
christophe martet andré saura chronique
d'une élection attendue
aux cris de viva vesle vive le président
la foule massée devant le château de
frags accueilli vaclav havel
le nouveau visage de la démocratie
retrouvée en tchécoslovaquie
je vous remercie tous tchèques et
slovaques et toutes les nationalités de
notre pays pour votre soutien et je vous
promets de ne pas trahir votre confiance
et de conduire ce pays vers les
élections libres c'est un moment unique
et une bonne occasion pour voir le
champagne cette élection c'est le
premier pas vers la liberté et la
démocratie
je suis très enthousiaste j'attendais ce
moment depuis des années c'est l'homme
juste à la juste place
ce matin la cérémonie de l'élection
était conduite par l'autre symboles de
cette révolution tranquille
alexandre do check l'homme du printemps
de prague désormais président de
l'assemblée fédérale
et c'est à l'unanimité que vaclav havel
a été élu images incroyables de ces
députés communistes applaudissant celui
qui hier encore était l'ennemi numéro un
du régime
premier président non communiste depuis
1948 vaclav havel a aussi voulu renouer
avec une tradition banni par l'ancien
régime
la messe de bénédiction
en ce moment même les habitants de
prague danse dans les rues pour fêter ce
qu'ils considèrent comme leur plus belle
récompense de fin d'année en france deux
policiers ont été tués à la suite d'une
fusillade à nîmes
cela s'est passé hier soir la fusillade
opposait les policiers à l'un des évadés
de la prison de mende en lozère le
gangster a lui aussi été tué bruno roger
petit il n'y avait plus d'issue possible
pour am-dam djemaa au terme de sa cavale
22h38 hier soir quatre policiers en
patrouille ils prennent en chasse une
volkswagen golf qui venait de brûlé
plusieurs feux tricolores la voiture est
arrêtée
des coups de feu claquent de policier
éric garcia et michel ne vaut tous les
deux pères de famille sont tués à am-dam
djemaa l'occupant de la golf trouve lui
aussi la mort dans la fusillade tragique
épilogue d'une cavale commencé le 10
décembre dernier
ce jour-là am-dam gma s'était évadé de
la prison de mende en compagnie de trois
autres détenus tous dangereux et
condamnés à de lourdes peines de
réclusion
depuis quelques jours les forces de
police de la région étaient en état d'
alerte
elle soupçonnait en effet les quatre
malfrats de préparer un hold up dans la
région de nîmes ce soir
la cavale est terminée pour ramdam
djemaa mais elle continue pour ses trois
compagnons toujours en fuite et qui
n'ont rien à perdre
oui au même moment l'un des prisonniers
évadés d'une autre prison celle de
lannemezan été arrêté à tunis il s'était
évadé le 6 décembre dernier avec huit
autres détenus à bordeaux ludovic
produite a été inculpé de parricide et
d'homicides il est soupçonné d'être le
meurtrier de quatre personnes de sa
famille
c'était la semaine dernière le drame de
castelvieilh bruno roger-petit
considérée jusque-là comme témoin numéro
un dans la sphère du massacre de
castelvieilh ludovic audouy a été ramené
au palais de justice de bordeaux pour
être entendue par un juge d'instruction
de nombreux soupçons peser sur ce jeune
homme de 27 ans gardien à la prison de
la santé il était en congés au moment
des faits et n'avait pas repris son
travail à l'issue de ses vacances il
était réapparue mercredi dernier en
espagne ces déclarations
corey rend aux juges espagnols ont
probablement amené son homologue
français alain juppé d'homicide et de
parricide
l'enquète l'information se poursuivant
dans les heures qui sut qui viennent et
dans une jours qui viennent par la
vérification des éléments matériels et
notamment par l'examen psychiatrique
rapide de jean-marc ludovic audit
refusant de répondre aux questions du
juge au cours de son premier
interrogatoire ludovic audouy sera
écroué dès ce soir à la prison de
gradignan
bonne et mauvaise nouvelle pour le 1er
janvier il s'agit de chiffres alors je
vous les énumère d'abord les timbres les
timbres de deux bras de 2 francs 20 à 2
francs 30 pour les lettres ordinaire à
partir du 11 janvier prochain
les voeux de noël seront donc encore au
tarif anciens en compensation une bonne
nouvelle le tarif interurbain du
téléphone va baisser à la même date
d'environ 6% pour les moins favorisés
augmentation du rmi revenu minimum
d'insertion dès le 1er janvier une
augmentation de 2 7%
je vous rappelle que 480 mille ménages
bénéficient de ce errani et puis enfin
encore un chiffre cette fois pour le
commerce extérieur et c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle en octobre dernier il ya eu un
déficit de 8 milliards 676 millions de
francs en données corrigées des
variations saisonnières un chiffre trop
élevé phillips acier qui amène à se
poser des questions sur les conséquences
monétaires de ces mauvais chiffres on se
les pose effectivement le dollar baisse
hervé les américains n'ont de mule
produit le déficit de la france avec les
etats-unis a doublé en octobre par
rapport à la moyenne des derniers mois
le crédit y est plus chère en grande
bretagne et les anglais achètent moins
de produits à l'étranger notre excédent
commercial avec l'angleterre a fondu
comme beurre au soleil
la guerre froide et cède peu à peu le
pas à l'entente cordiale est ouest
l'iran et l'irak ont cessé le feu
les marchands de canons ne font plus
recette l'excédent de nos ventes d'armes
est au plus bas niveau de l'année
bref la france consomme trop et ne vont
pas à ces résultats
un déficit prévu de 50 milliards pour
cette année un chiffre effectivement
inquiétant pour le franc au moment où le
mark allemand dopé par les événements de
l'est grimpe à toute allure contre
toutes les monnaies occidentales du coup
on parle de plus en plus d'un
réaménagement monétaire en europe les
français que l'on fait de la
désinflation et du front
or les deux piliers d'une politique qui
commence à porter ses fruits devront et
probablement dans les semaines qui
viennent faire face à une des premières
épreuves de 1990 une réévaluation du
marque à laquelle ils veulent faire
coller le front français
c'est un défi mais si ça marche c'est
bien le couple rocard bérégovoy réussir
à hervé une grande première historique
merci philippe j'ajoute cette
information politique dont je viens de
prendre connaissance sur l'écran de mon
ordinateur
le conseil constitutionnel a déclaré
conforme à la constitution la loi de
finances 90 et le collectif budgétaire
il a donc racheté le recours qui avait
été déposé par l'information
parlementaire
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
de ce vendredi est tout d'abord ces
menaces d'attentât contre un avion de
ligne américain
la compagnie américaine a annoncé aux
passagers avant le vol
les risques qu'ils couraient louis
carzou le vol 0,51 paris détroit de
samedi sera maintenu malgré les menaces
reçues par la compagnie northwest
airlines la compagnie aérienne
américaine a annoncé que le fbi la cia
et les services français concernés
avaient été alertés pour assurer la
sécurité de ce vol
cependant les passagers qui le
souhaitaient ont pu changer d'avion
c'est la première fois qu'une compagnie
aérienne annonce au passage et les
menaces dans cette fait l'objet
violente altercation entre 3000
manifestants palestiniennes israéliennes
et européennes et la police aujourd'hui
à jérusalem
les forces de l'ordre sont intervenues
dans ce qu'un drapeau palestinien est
apparue au milieu du cortège le plus
important en faveur de la paix depuis le
début de l'intifada 16 manifestantes ont
été arrêtées parmi lesquelles une
italienne député européen
cérémonie de recueillement cet
après-midi à paris à la mémoire des
trois français tués au soudan il y avait
jour le 21 décembre dernier un avion
d'aviation sans frontières avec à son
bord deux membres de médecins sans
frontières étaient abattus havel au
soudan
pour la première fois depuis dix ans la
sncf va dégager des excédents 89 d'un
montant de 200 millions de francs c'est
dans le message de fin d'année aux
cheminots que la bonne nouvelle a été
annoncée la moitié de cet excédent
devraient d'ailleurs être consacrés à
l'amélioration des conditions
matérielles de travail
ces investissements seront également en
hausse en 90 jusqu'à 60 % de plus pour
le tgv
marché très peu actif à la bourse de
paris où l'on se préoccuper plus de
cotillons que de cotation aujourd'hui
la séance s'est achevée sur une légère
hausse de 0,11 pour cent et les fêtes
sont de nouveau du goût du dollar la
devise américaine a repris un peu de
couleurs à 5 francs 78,81 un ouf de
soulagement pour philippe poupon et pour
tous ceux qui s'intéressent à la course
autour du monde sans escale poupon avait
lancé un appel de détresse il hier en
fait son bateau avait chaviré comme un
dériveur il a dû passer 24 heures sur la
coque et puis loïck peyron un autre
concurrent est arrivé et ils ont
redresser le bateau de poupon alors
voici comment les choses ont dû se
passer
patrick 9 filou est vivant philou c'est
le surnom de philippe poupon
après 30 heures d'angoissé il est repéré
ce matin par un avion sud africain à
2000 kilomètres au sud du cap de bonne
espérance
reste le problème du sauvetage le plus
proche de philippe poupon et loïck
peyron après s'être déroutée hier soir
perd on repère le naufragé vers 10
heures ce matin son bateau et uche et
sur le côté probablement à cause du
couple négatif d'un ballast au lieu d'en
marquer à bord de la dap hoc
les deux hommes essaient de remettre le
bateau à flot opération délicate
puisqu'il faut démonter le mât d'artimon
opération réussie qui sauve donc
également le bateau de philippe poupon
un bateau très mal en point que son
skipper va sans doute diriger vers le
cap pour lui l'aventuré terminée il sera
vraisemblablement disqualifié
quant à loïc théron il reprend la course
dans laquelle il occupe toujours la
seconde place il va s'attaquer
maintenant à la traversée du plus grand
désert maritime de la planète
direction le cap horn
voilà il me reste maintenant à vous
donner quelques informations pratiques
comme chaque soir à la fin de ce journal
d'abord le tiercé avec les pronostics
pour la course de demain les pronostics
de pierrette brès
les voici nous allons les voir sur
l'écran il s'agit d'un tiercé quarté +
qui se court à vincennes il y a vingt
partants pirette propose de jouer le 14
le sceptre le 19 le dise le 6 le 18 le 5
et le 16
la météo c'est dans quelques minutes
avec laurent cabrol la dernière édition
du journal ce sera philippe gassot ce
soir vers 23h40 pour le week-end vous
retrouverez outre philippe gassot rachid
arhab à 13 heures et à 20 heures avec
betty dureau à la rédaction en chef
comme d'habitude alors bon week-end à
tous et à l'année prochaine